[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer at the observers on your
soda and the chief executive of
conservative home mark Wallace lovely to
see both of you so as ever let's take a
look at the front pages starting with
the financial times the bank of
England's latest intervention buying
guilts again to prevent fire sales by
Pension funds the paper tells us the
telegraph also has the latest on the
country's economic turmoil they lead
with Sterling Falls as the bank pulls
the plug on that pension help
the eye tells us of truss's latest move
to silence Rebels with a cap on energy
profits a move aimed at saving taxpayers
billions the guardian also covers the
energy crisis the headline power Giants
to face a windfall tax after all as
trust delivers a U-turn the express
details the King's latest Demands a
slimmed down coronation to more
accurately reflect the country's cost of
living crisis
the Metro leads with the chilling case
of alleged baby killer Lucy leppy the
headline trust me I'm a nurse this is
what the court heard during the second
day of the trial
The Daily Mirror Has a plea from James
bulger's mother to prime minister Liz
truss don't let James's killer walk free
she pleads ahead of his parole hearing
as well as the legacy of Dame Angela
Lansbury right at the top there
and the star headlines or features this
headline rather I love you to the moon
and back a not so successful space
romance as a fake astronaut tricks a
woman out of 27 000 pounds to rescue him
from space is that all it would cost a
reminder by scanning the QR code you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you listen to our
guests so let's head to them then uh
Sonia and Mark are with us um so let's
catch up with the latest economic news
shall we both the financial times and
the Daily Telegraph leading on the
decision by the bank of England to stop
this help effectively to Pension funds
uh Sonia and what that means both
economically and politically take it
away if you can
well I think it's quite worrying so on
the one hand we've got the bank of
England launching another intervention
today to buy guilds
um so that's an intervention to help
save Pension funds but one thing the
governor of the bank of England is
really worried about is that it becomes
sort of inbuilt in the system that
whenever there are issues the bank of
England will step in it will bail
Pension funds out of some of these
structural issues and it's also trying
to give a very strong signal that this
help is not never ending in fact it's
saying it's going to end by Friday so
Pension funds have to sort of try and
restructure to make themselves more
sustainable in a very uncertain
environment
um by Friday so
um it's really difficult and I think it
comes I mean I'm sort of no Financial
expert on this
um but I think what it comes down to is
the fact that
um you've got two different institutions
pulling against each other so you've got
the government that is actually
promising lots of tax cuts which is
quite expansionary what the what
economists call expansionary for the
economy it expands demand but at the
same time you've got the bank of England
trying to act to limit interest rates
which is you know tend to go up when
demand goes up that can have a terrible
impact for example people's mortgages
and so they're they're coming in with a
contractionary monetary policy and so
essentially you've got two sets of
Institutions tugging against each other
doing opposite things and this is one of
the effects that's caused this issue for
Pension funds so it doesn't feel very
sustainable right now I think is is one
way of putting it yes indeed and uh Mr
Bailey stressing that the program was
part of the bank of England's Financial
stability operations not part of its
monetary policy so therefore had to be
temporary
um saying to pension fund managers
you've got three days left now you've
got to get this done well the industry
body had urged the the bank of England
to extend it to your over the 31st and
even Beyond anyway where does this leave
this trust of the chancellor politically
then Mark
well the first thing you can say is it
leaves the government in an extremely
difficult position because of course one
of the kind of um Prime laws of British
politics since the 1990s is that the
bank of England is independent the
government I fully expect obviously will
be asked to comment on the governor's
latest comments and his decision and so
on and the government will say what
every government does which is that the
bank of England's independent and they
don't meddle with how it does things
um that doesn't make the issue go away
and it doesn't change the fact that
um when there's economic uh turbulence
and economic bad news for obvious
reasons people look to the government
um and and allocate responsibility at
their doorstep that basically is an
unsquarable Circle for for politicians I
think in that particular instance to
just add to what Sonia just said you
know she's right about these kind of
competing tensions between the kind of
policy impact of the government and the
bank that is a
um kind of more immediate contributing
you know trigger for what why we are
where we are and it's certainly going to
continue to make this situation
difficult but what we're also seeing is
this is the outcome of a very long-term
series of issues that have been
developing for the best part of two
decades you know we've had it's been
clear for a very long time that the
effects of artificially cheap money uh
they are artificially cheap credit
printing vast amounts of money you know
even even before covid
um for years and years on end was
storing up major kind of issues
um in a variety of core markets and at
some point those were going to unwind
there's not not the case in this country
it's in the case other countries as as
well to varying degrees at some point
those were going to unwind and it would
be a mistake to assume that you could
kind of defy gravity and levitate your
way out of these things forever the
issue of course is that now what we're
seeing is these things unwinding
precipitously fast and hard and
painfully
um
issues for many people is that the bank
of England will spend so much time
trying to tackle whatever the
government's doing in its policy terms
that it will distract from what its core
aim right now has to be for all of us
which is to reduce inflation and that I
think that's you know what partly shook
the markets isn't it Mark
yeah I'm sorry good Mark you just
finished off because I interrupted you
sorry
that's part of the fact that you know
they've got competing tasks to do your
financial stability includes stability
in the in in the the pension markets for
example it's interesting one of the
reasons I suspect the bank feels so
strongly about this they're giving this
kind of stock you've got three days to
deal with it warning is they did warn
the pensions to be four years ago on
this topic but the problem they had is
people looked at that warning and
thought interest rates aren't going to
go back to what they uh once uh what was
once normal that's not coming back they
didn't believe them and uh and so then
now they have three days to unwind what
was meant to be Unwound in four years
the question then is going to be do they
look at the bank and think are you
serious you're playing chicken with us
are you if we don't unwind this by
Friday are you actually going to let us
get into worse trouble next week or is
the bank going to go back on its words
and step in again and that's at that
point that you know blows away another
tool that the governor's disposal well
the Daily Telegraph um suggests there
are fears of more chaos to come
suggesting that mistrust was challenged
at cabinet over plans to cut benefits in
real terms with four ministers
understood to support an inflation link
rise Liz trust the paper says has vowed
to meet MPS to discuss their concerns
this is what Wednesday is all about
isn't it pmqs in the tea rooms
presumably in the meantime two
newspapers are talking about another
U-turn the guardian and the eye so let's
take a look at the guardian first of all
renewable power companies will have
revenues capped in England and Wales
after the government bowed to pressure
to curb runaway profits Renewable Power
companies um Sonia
so yeah absolutely so laborer claiming
this as a win
um because one of the things they've
been arguing is that the war in Ukraine
has pushed Energy prices up massively
everywhere which has basically delivered
a huge windfall benefit to North Sea oil
producers to renewable producers of
energy as well and so one of the things
that Labor's been arguing is that Rishi
sunax windfall tax there were lots of
exemptions
um lots of tax deductibles in that tax
essentially meant it raised a fairly
limited amount so labor have been
arguing you need to raise more by upping
that tax and removing some of the
exemptions for energy producers now it
sounds like what the government is go is
planning on doing it is a huge U-turn
it's a big Market intervention and the
suggestion seems to be that there will
be a cap going forwards on the revenues
of energy producers in the UK so that
would for example include North Sea
Island Renewables now that might be a
slightly different mechanism to the
windfall Taps that labor was talking
about but at the end of the day it's
still a huge Market intervention along
the same principles that label was
arguing for so that's I think why labor
is claiming it as a victory and also
another very significant U-turn because
Liz truss and quasiquarting said they
weren't going to do this they announced
a package of energy interventions in the
in the so-called mini budget three weeks
ago and they promised a huge program of
tax cuts unfunded tax cuts at The
Institute for fiscal studies has come
out and said today would require 60
billion pounds worth of spending cuts to
make the the book sound up but they
weren't going to come in and take extra
intervention on the energy industry and
it now looks like they are u-turning
from that and the eye says that the
business secretary Jacoby smorg
um will cut this move will cut bills
because soaring wholesale gas prices
will no longer dictate electricity
prices bringing the UK into line with
much of the EU which is you know this
anomaly we've had isn't it about what
sets the price of electricity
effectively Mark but do you see this as
a U-turn and a labor awareness Sonia
does
well undoubtedly is a U-turn um labor
obviously going to claim claim that as a
victory and understandably so I think
that that in itself makes you know
present some minor more minor challenges
for labor the fact is that if this
doesn't have the full desired effect
um do they then say well we would have
done it a little bit differently or what
we'll have to wait and see
um this is part of the difficulty and we
were dealing a couple of weeks ago we're
all talking about purely what what felt
like simply an economic confidence
crisis or Market confidence crisis as
soon as you U-turn you as happened on
45p you create a political and
particularly Commons arithmetic
confidence crisis the question of uh
whether an MP will go out and stick
their necks out and stand by the
government some MPS I was talking to
before the toy conference were unusually
and not their normal mode privately
supportive but keeping storm in public
is they wanted to see if the new boss
was like the old boss where they got
used to Boris making them look silly by
sticking their necks out to back him up
and then pulled the ropes under them at
the last minute that there's a risk that
that becomes a spiral for the government
in that uh you know next time fewer MPS
are willing to take the risk of backing
you because they think you might be a
you might be about a U-turn again so it
gets harder to hold your line again a
U-turn becomes more likely so just very
in a word one word answer should there
have been no u-turns um in order to
maintain
um
executive
um Authority
uh i i i a one-word answer will be no
but slightly starting a long answer you
know I simply think that their position
became won by their arithmetic didn't
add UPS they had to okay practicalities
there I suppose and say that lots more
still to come including the Metro which
covers the chilling trial of the alleged
baby killer Lucy Lips
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again the
chief leader writer of The Observers on
yasoda and the chief executive of
conservative home mark Wallace welcome
back to both of you
um so let's talk about Ukraine and
Russia in fact and indeed how Middle
Eastern countries are dealing with this
um from page picture of the Ft Mark a
visit uh to Russia by the UAE
um this is interesting isn't it because
they helped broker along with Saudi
Arabia and turkey a prisoner exchange
last month but the Americans are
obviously watching this closely to see
International alignments and who backs
who in the war
yes it's quite a shocking image I think
really when you think about recent
months the fact that at long last the
word Pariah status has started to seem
like it has some meaning when applied to
Vladimir Putin and Russia after so long
are people indulging a variety of vile
and violent uh acts out around the world
by the Kremlin to actually see the
president of the UAE there in Saint
Petersburg shaking hands with Russia's
dictator in the middle of this war is is
quite Stark and I think it it really
underscores the fact that the age of
kind of moral relative relativism of
kind of
um you know they're out there maybe are
badied but there are badly to have a
broadcast friendly paraphrase of a a
cold war quote about dictators has has
to be over you know we need to start
insisting in the west that there are
tough questions that people like say the
UAE there's another story
um on the front page of the guardian and
with the the Americans for Australia
nation that Saudi
um acting on the OPEC policy in a way
that helps the team to help Russia as
well
um these countries cannot have it both
ways they need to start deciding whether
they wish to Proclaim themselves to be
allies and aligned with the Western
World or whether they wish to be to
flock together as birds of a feather
with other despots and you know it's
long been clear we shouldn't be reliant
on uh dictatorships of any sort for our
energy Vladimir Putin's actions have
underscored that with gas from Russia
It's also two very starkly of of oil
from a variety of other tyrannies yeah
just one minute left I mean we remember
post 911 don't we Sonia the axis of Evil
are you with us or against us slight
sense of that too and asked tonight if
Saudi Arabia is aligning with Russia on
Ukraine a White House spokesperson said
We Believe on that ope plus decision
that they are aligning with Russia and
this Guardian article suggesting that
the Biden Administration is consider
during tough new measures against Saudi
Arabia
yeah actually I mean my thoughts on it
are maybe it shouldn't have taken it to
get to this stage to take this approach
to Saudi Arabia there were also huge
questions about Saudi Arabia's um human
rights record for example domestically
against
um journalists for example Jamal
um uh khashoggi for example what
happened to him so I do think that um
absolutely we need to sort of consider
that now but there's been a lot of red
flags about country like Saudi Arabia as
Marx just said in the run-up to this and
I think you've got to think about the
Strategic alliances that you make and
whether they're right on a principled
basis not just on a sort of you know is
this going to work for me in the next
five to ten years or to basis
and a final look at one of the
newspapers this was uh late uh news
um the sad news that Dame Angela
Lansbury Mark has died as well at the
age of 96 just a few days short of her
90 27th birthday
yes I'm sure a lot of people will have
different favorite roles for me She'll
always be Miss eglantine price from
Bedknobs and Broomsticks um a film I
recently watched with my kids and they
loved it just as much as previous
generations did Mark Sonia lovely to
have you both on thank you both very
much indeed